here's what would happen if abortion was  illegal worldwide  governments might ban abortions but that  wouldn't mean there wouldn't be any  every day  125 000 women around the world get  abortions they'd be dangerous and might  even kill them but it's a risk that many  would have to take if the world took on  the same abortion laws as they have in  today's el salvador these women would be  sentenced to eight years in prison  prisons would be overwhelmed and many  women trapped in a motherhood they  didn't want would suffer from anxiety  and low self-esteem  the only industry to cash in on the  abortion ban would be the birth control  industry  and a number of people in developed  countries would opt for sterilization  the world would see at least one and a  half billion more people being born in  the next 40 years at that rate by 2060  there'd be too many humans for our  planet to support so